le preguntó entonces cómo pasaron la
noche los habitantes de kiev y qué es lo
último que nos puede reportar
pues ha sido una noche muy agitada y de
poco dormir a las a partir de las cuatro
y media de la madrugada se han
producido diversos estallidos y algunos
estallidos fueron provocados por el
derribamiento de un avión en un barrio
residencial en las afueras de quiebra
los ciudadanos lo que evitas han
transcurrido la noche escondiéndose en
sus casas o escondiéndose en los
centenares de refugios que hay en la
ciudad como hemos hecho también nosotros
que hemos dormido realmente muy poco por
esta razón porque las sirenas antiaéreas
han sonado más veces señalando diversas
expresiones en la ciudad pues me imagino
una noche que no ha sido para nada fácil
irene y le pregunta entonces qué se sabe
a esta hora del avance de las tropas
rusas hacia kiev y por qué es tan
importante el control que se ejerce
sobre la planta chernóbil
por supuesto a tratarse de una noticia
en desarrollo y de un contexto
particularmente buena volátil las
informaciones que tenemos son parciales
pero el ministerio de defensa ha
informado que en
en el distrito del blog ya habría
presencia rusa de tropas rusas o de
perdón de
unidades de exploración y sabotaje ruso
y así se estaría llevando también a cabo
un enfrentamiento con estas unidades y
otros otras fuentes han informado
también de la presencia de tanques rusos
que estarían siendo
el ejercio de ucrania estaría intentando
frenar su avance hacia la ciudad de
quiebre en una localidad que está un
poquito más lejos que es la localidad de
iván inc
que también se encuentra en el norte de
hacia el norte digamos de donde
estaciona claro irene también le quiero
preguntar que puede reportarnos de la
situación en otras ciudades de ucrania
se han producido se ha producido hoy por
la primera vez una
situación también peculiar en la ciudad
del ibi que se encuentra en el oeste por
tanto en la zona que hasta ahora había
sido menos afectada por las operaciones
bélicas
allí en los ciudadanos se han despertado
como ha pasado aquí en quiebra con el
sonido de las sirenas antiaéreas que
anunciaban
estallidos en partes de la ciudad
está esta situación es completamente
nueva porque la parte oeste hasta ahora
había sido la menos tocada por las
operaciones que es esta que está
llevando a cabo el ejército ruso en
ucrania la invasión rusa en ucrania
irene gracias como siempre por su
reporte por la labor que usted está
haciendo en pues uno de los focos
principales de este conflicto la capital
ucraniana kiev